I'm fat Castiel the angel of Doritos my
name's Colin I'm all the way from Texas
we do need to introduce that character
that's out Andrew are you taking those
no no I think you love to reduce dinner
so I have a question and if I'm able to
ask it if not I have a backup question
but in honor of season 12 I actually had
a very special question for my
girlfriend yes yes are you sure yeah
will you come up here that was your
question that was your question you use
it up mustache I know about the show so
we've been watching your show from the
very beginning and we want to share this
very special moment with our friends and
family here at comic-con
we love you all thank you very much for
everything that you do and I want to say
to you my love I loved you since the
very first moment that I saw you you
were the Sun that brightens my day and
you were the moon of my life I can't
think of anybody else I would want by my
side slaying zombies and killing
vampires and killing demons and whatever
else is out there
Wendy goes those things so what I'm
trying to ask you I think this comes on
let's try it out okay
um Ashley Elizabeth Rhodes will you
marry me
kiss her kiss her yes
all right get a room kill someone get a
room
thank you guys what was the backup
question I want to know what the backup
question was so the back of questioning
would and a bag of Doritos
thanks a lot she said yes never been
hail biter
so my backup question was for several
seasons we're trying to figure out who
had the deeper voice was it Cass or was
it Dean so I don't know what's in it for
all who's I think unfortunately I think
Mark Sheppard takes the cake on that he
had his vocal cords surgically alternate
in all fairness um Mark Sheppard also
talks about 20 hours a day so I think
it's very warm down so it's just very
it's definitely it's definitely worn
down um you love love love can we get a
voice off congrats guys congratulations
yeah we should not vote seeking medical
attention for the fortress trying to
keep up with a witch hardship to keep
the throat down here but yeah I haven't
done my vocal warm-ups but I'll do my
best as a line that you guys know I'm
the one who gripped you tight and raised
you from perdition uncanny
what are you he sounds like that in the
morning uh how do you know
ha
- icon that was it's a Claddagh that was
the background quest
I still can't work out why that was the
backup question it's like if she says no
I want to know who had the deeper voice
I mean how does that go together hey why
were you gonna pick one of the two of
them and ask them instead it would
however it would have been funny if he
was like um I'd like to ask my
girlfriend a question and he raises the
box of like oh no no don't do that cuz
then he'd be like oh I was just kidding
hahaha no good that's the spot Congrats
guys thanks for the question yeah I
think it's a beautiful thing when a
satanically theme television show can
bring people together
yeah yeah that may have been one of the
first wedding proposals that included
talking up the people you're going to
kill together we're gonna kill demons I
want him as one of the demons on the
show I like him
you